can a kid chef beat an amateur home cook
in a cooking competition the answer is
yes hi guys I'm Kyle I'm 12 years old
and I competed on MasterChef junior
season 7 I've been cooking for almost
nine years now my grandma taught me how
to cook during the holidays in the
kitchen and from there I kind of took it
to a new level and taught myself how to
cook what's up guys I'm Vic I work here
at BuzzFeed people probably know me in
the office here is like the resident
cook Hey
hi I'm Kyle nice to meet you ready I'm
ready I don't know if you're ready I'm
gonna kick your butt well maybe that's
why you've been winning excuse me it
makes a little intimidated by meat but
it's trying to like you know keep a
strong face but I think inside it's very
afraid I'm a little bit nervous so I see
it was my little friends on MasterChef
and those type of shows could do I think
I could hold my own you guys say I think
Kyle's gonna be it for a little bit of a
surprise so what's the challenge and say
I'm I'm pretty familiar with leftovers
actually one of the ways I started
cooking was through what I called the
leftover remix where I take a bunch of
stuff left over from lunch and try to
make something new I'm a little
experience in this way good luck you'll
need it I'll need it we'll see all right
what do you have here I see mac and
cheese turkey mashed sweet potatoes you
know some of the normal stuff they have
leftover I see some cornmeal in the
pantry flour some sugar so I think I'm
kind of getting a really good idea in my
head right now when I think of
Thanksgiving you know I think of like
super Cheetos and so I repurpose them
kind of and make it superior cornbread
and when you really think a super to do
some Thanksgiving you think it more like
a casserole with marshmallows so I'm
gonna actually put my special twist on
that and make it a cornbread with
marshmallows I'm gonna add some pumpkin
butter till you know lighten it up a bit
I don't think it can match this dish all
right let's see what we have
[Music]
interesting I see shredded mozzarella
cheese I see shredded cheddar cheese
looks like some mashed potatoes some
veggies Oh corn bread excellent
excellent
all these things I could definitely use
put together me being Hispanic not
really the ingredients that I'm used to
seeing around Thanksgiving these are
quite bland and unimpressive leftovers I
think I'm coming together with a little
bit of a plan I got some cheese I got
some turkey mashed potatoes corn bread
gravy what I'm thinking is I'm gonna
incorporate put all these things a
little bit together right chop them
stuff up make like a leftover ball
something that you know can incorporate
all these ingredients here and then
maybe take some of this cornbread and
see if we could pulverize it use it as
like a breading of some sorts because
very similar to what we would call like
a pop out of the mm you like an
appetizer food are you make them big and
it's like a whole meal but I just want
to throw a little bit of that Hispanic
flair in there just to put my own little
spin on these Thanksgiving leftovers
yeah let's see if we could try to give
Kyle a little run for his money it
should be a flavor bomb
I've always watched those shows and I've
wondered like are these kids really as
good as they portrayed them to be it's
just movie magic I don't know but I
think today we're definitely to find out
yes we are ready to go
[Music]
locked in
why are you doing over there I'm
adjusting as champions often have to do
okay we'll see how's everything over
there God oh it's good you know just I
forgot the top hahaha
you didn't hear anything so covering the
top of my hand probably wasn't the
safest thing I'm sure there was a couple
bits of bread left over the place but it
all no it worked
hey Vic um I heard you needed some eggs
and I also need some sweet corn and then
Kyle had the audacity koji hate me he
makes that [ __ ] of yourself you
should have been prepared Kyle but I was
also prepared so I was willing to make
the trade you know let's just help me
out before I'll do that trade for you
okay I have some sweet corn here thank
you
eggs thank you come both speaking oil
just in case the oil and the other
skillet burned it's gonna be good
[Music]
hear that sizzle
so after I put the corn bread in the
oven I had to rush and make my pumpkin
butter before I can work it out
can I use a tad bit of breadcrumbs put
these fillings in omec
what's up it looks like you're sweating
over there I slept standing still
I assure you cows not because I'm
nervous or anything okay he was so
nervous cuz I think he was scared of me
that he started sweating in his food I
don't know if that impacted the taste of
his food but yeah have my own
handy-dandy towel oh good I thought
maybe there was some sort of way that I
could kind of take him out of the zone
think you're gonna be able to finish
it's definitely gonna be a little kick
concentrate on what you're doing make
these fritters they're gonna be the best
and we're gonna crush top
[Applause]
I saw that he used the cornbread and the
breadcrumbs to make a coating for the
printer and I thought that was really
creative that he did that
Wow I might have some competition here
so there is a delicate balance between
totally burning the marshmallows and
having a really good cook cornbread I
need to navigate that delicate balance
and make sure that both components are
cooked evenly and well
at first Kyle seemed like he was very
confident but after a while or nothing
from the other side a little bit of you
got leaked try to just delicately guide
them into the pan five minutes left
basically done quick cornbread quick
butter plated like nice and rustic Leon
a nice wooden board and Mickey's still
struggling to finish his dish and there
we have it nice homey cozy cornbread
skillet with marshmallows and pumpkin
butter at master chef Gordon Ramsay
always taught me to taste taste taste my
food I really really enjoyed how it
tasted and I think I'm gonna blow the
judges away today
sokar I feel like I'm a little old now a
little out of touch of the days what
kind of music you like man what are you
into with that baby shark song what did
he just say baby shark I know you know
that one they all know it oh I'm sorry
for debts I have no idea what the chords
are they were popular in the fifties
just I'm now old come on cut it out cop
twenty nine is not old I know I am a
little old but that's alright because
with age comes experience I'm hoping can
I try some back oh not bad rule do me a
favor dunk a little bit in that green
view oh you missed some of that it's
[ __ ] gonna stick as nice as I want it
to look and look
why you got this face like you're eating
vegetables he's lying do you see it no
oh should we bring the judges down yeah
I think we're gonna need them because
you were a little biased yes good luck
good luck ah okay it's pretty good I
think it's just like fried potato
broccoli but it's a little simple Wow
I like is cheesy inside in the middle
there's some chicken in there that's
real good this is new to me I never had
this type of style before I was not
expecting for there to be mashed
potatoes in it you can't really see and
then you cut it open and it's like this
gooey mashed potato wonder comes out and
then I got very excited because mashed
potatoes are the best Thanksgiving food
overall it's pretty good what this is so
good it's like sweet but not too sweet
it's like a dessert very sweet very
tasty I don't know I'm not really
digging the corn the flavor is very good
I'm very big on flavor there's like a
cinnamon butter that you put on top and
that makes such a difference I think
this is absolutely amazing
it's warm and the perfect like cake
consistency it's not too moist it's a
terrible word between these two dishes
if I had to pick one I would go with the
second one because I'm very big on
flavor the first one just the flavor
wasn't there addition to add anymore so
out of these two dishes I think my
favorite has to be the mashed potato
ball I just love savory foods and mashed
potatoes are the best and I think mashed
potatoes are really hard to eat the next
day and make it done well and I'm taking
one of these to go out of these two
dishes I think my favorite is gonna have
to be
the second one I've never tried anything
like that
pumpkin cornbread with this very cool
presentation I thought this was tasty
and if I got it I wouldn't be mad but it
wasn't anything like wow I've never
tried this before this this is awesome
[Music]
in this time taste of a mature adults
home cook versus kid chef leftover
Thanksgiving challenge the winner is it
really did I was admiring it from over
here and I had a little bit of a pit in
my stomach because I was like look at my
guy he's got all these machines going
he's got his little cast-iron skillet
everything was beautiful he's organized
but it was fun nonetheless I'm very
happy for the opportunity and you really
kicked butt man
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]